I asked last week, but did not write out the video was not there. But I do write during
the day also and use to amplify the jackhammer module as I'm not always sitting. Do I need
to use the grounding mat? No, you don't. You don't need to use the grounding mat with the
jackhammer. The only thing is by if you use the jackhammer it increases the amplification
mat. If you have it right up, if you have the bulb right up to your tummy, you are going
to basically put it a charge on your skin. Like if you walked around in a dry house on
the carpet of your socks and you dragged your feet and then you go touch it a little and
you get a shock. That is just an electrostatic charge on your skin of electrons because you
are rubbing your feet on the floor and you're picking up your producing an electric
that electron charge. You can also do that with the right machine, you're picking up electrons.
Those are good things, okay? But it's not feel good when somebody comes and discharges
it on you and touches you and you both get a shock. It doesn't feel good. It's not wrong with
it. It's just that using the grounding mat can help grow that if you want it to. You don't
need to use a grounding mat. I never suggest using a chap to use a grounding mat when you're
using the bulb. So yes, it works just as well without it really doesn't work. It doesn't
make it work any better.